je viens de nantes la digue la digue la
digue du cul alors leslie on va tout de
suite accueillir nos chroniqueurs et on
va jouer à miss tahiti douche
j'appelle notre premier miss notre
première miss d'ailleurs ses premiers
miss on peut dire miss loire atlantique
[Applaudissements]
je viens de nantes 1 la tri glazig la
digue de cul mais je vais je veux
surtout je veux défendre de toutes les
femmes je veux des fleurs à toutes les
femmes je vais défendre la cause des
femmes révèle délicate est élégance ici
il faut poser c'est 'qui sur la table je
le trouve accueillons maintenant miss
meurthe et boulettes goulard martégaux
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama va bientôt de nouvelles manettes
va bien très belle en blonde tu vas pas
ce que tu es là je te jure winstrat
qu'alain muskoka l'histoire n'est ce pas
qu'alain
cette levée
on a qu à l élégance comme temps mais
c'est sa merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là franchement la très bonne
affaire
elle l'a pas mis des rues parce que j'ai
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi
oui elle a le droit d'aller venus boire
gentiment dans ma loge à elle m'a dit
cyril je ne peux pas mettre de perruques
voilà parce que j'ai envie d'y aller
comme ça jeudi christine tuer la reine
alors il faut aller dans bach
[Applaudissements]
tout ça
l'eau miss pyrénées à la marche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
cosy et bien on dirait qu en fait j'ai
enfin qui m'a pas envie de vous écouter
ni speight savoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien plus belles où se côtoient
qu'elle est belle c'est ma préférée on
accueille miss le texte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
j'attends vos flux attribue ce que j'ai
entendu il précisé j'ai préféré
j'ai eu des jumeaux classement dans la
tête sachez que vous êtes dans mon top 3
bien sûr non non non non non je l ai
dans mon top 3 à
les deux autres je peux vous le dire il
ya christine eia géraldine il n'ya pas
kelly a pas moi j'aime qu'on avait les
yeux braqués lit avec cette coiffure et
jeux et vous mais vous vous êtes bien
mais vous vous préférez naturel
également et vous vous risquez de
rentrer chez vous
[Rires]
[Musique]